- And so my fellow Americans
ask not what your country
can do for you, ask what
you can do for your country.
- All the time.
It is amazing to me that
for something that is so
fundamental to the
functioning of our country
that we have not invested
more in making it easier
and not harder for people to vote.
- If I learned anything
during my time working for
Bill Weld and Paul Cellucci
is that if you really
assumed that the Republicans
had all the right answers
or the Democrats had all
the right answers you
were likely to be wrong.
- At a time when young people
often feel disconnected from
politics we need to reach
across the generations
and recommit ourselves and
our country to these ideals.
- All this will not be
finished in the first 100 days.
Nor will it be finished
in the first 1,000 days.
Nor in the life of this administration,
nor even perhaps in our
lifetime on this planet.
But let us begin.